[Music]
the american south has long had a taste
for mexican food but one chef has
created a unique fusion of his very own
time changed we had to do something
different
i don't lose the fact or the focus that
i came from mexico and i want to make
sure that the food reflects my past into
the present
the sky is the limit we can do whatever
we want
i'm zoe saldana from bc and i'm teaming
up a great big story to shine a light on
american latinx excellence around the
country
[Music]
my name is eddie hernandez i'm the
co-owner of the careers del sol i'm the
executive chair eddie came to the u.s as
a teenager in 1974
with just 140 in his pocket
it took me three years to go from the
cleaning guy to the general manager of
the restaurant
today he runs a string of restaurants in
georgia and tennessee his success is
undeniably due to his clever approach to
each dish
i make different food i make something
that is different without losing the
taste of where i came from
[Music]
while eddie utilizes ingredients native
to mexico he keeps the american palate
in mind
tonight
i decided to do this thing and instead
of using the tabasco sauce with the
cayenne peppers i decided to use a dried
pepper which is a chili the other one on
the same family
they like to put ham hogs which i
thought they didn't click with mine so i
used chicken stock they like to eat it
with cornbread i like to eat it with
corn tortillas and today people learn to
eat tonight with tortillas because you
get the corn flavor anyway
[Music]
for eddie each dish takes time and
experimentation but the end result is
always worth it
i can taste
ingredients
and then
figure it out how can i get the best
flavor out of this culture and this
culture and this culture to create a new
product a new flavor
[Music]
you can put me in japan and i'm gonna
cook mexican food in japan australia it
doesn't matter to me
food is a reflection of a place it's a
reflection of who we are who we came
from and i think food is the one
ingredient that can put world leaders
together on one table and not kill each
other
you